[Música]
los bombardeos rusos se intensifican
sobre mikko life la última localidad
ucraniana que faltaría para que se
produzca el inminente ataque ruso sobre
el puerto de odessa considerado la perla
del mar negro
la guerra en ucrania podría afectar el
funcionamiento de la estación espacial
internacional
rusia alega que con las sanciones
internacionales tendría que dejar de
enviar los componentes que mantienen en
órbita la instalación
esta fue la primera jornada oficial de
gabriel boric como presidente de chile
el mandatario sostuvo una reunión con
representantes de los 10 pueblos
indígenas del país que aseguró que es
necesario fomentar una nueva relación
para que chile sea una nación digna y
justa
[Música]
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torres sánchez damos
inicio en ucrania se cumplen 17 días
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa y al
tiempo que se cierra el cerco alrededor
de kiev los bombardeos se intensificaron
sobre la localidad de mykolaiv el último
punto estratégico que faltaría tomar
para lanzar el temido ataque sobre
odessa un puerto clave para las líneas
vitales de suministro en el país veamos
más detalles en el informe
más allá de las orillas de esta playa no
des a los residentes temen que la flota
rusa se acerque mientras las fuerzas de
putin avanzan por toda la costa del mar
negro el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski advierte que esa es la
siguiente
sabemos que los barcos rusos no están
lejos
ayer estaba dando de comer a las
gaviotas y vi como el barco lanzaron
cinco misiles pero no tenemos miedo
peter aquí al momenin bahiense odessa es
la joya de la corona de las ciudades
costeras de ucrania y una pieza clave
para apoderarse del sur de la nación
capturarla costaría ucrania la salida al
mar y las líneas de suministros vitales
en estas imágenes filmadas por la marina
ucraniana se puede ver un barco ruso
disparando un misil hacia la costa las
autoridades temen un ataque marítimo de
rusia hace meses el ejército ucraniano
cubrió esta playa con minas ante la
amenaza de una invasión la zona costera
está muy vigilada
en esta playa los movilizados tienen
miles de sacos de arena que se
utilizarán para construir barricadas en
la ciudad no temen una invasión afirman
que un dique submarino les protegería si
los buques de guerra rusos se acercan
wander tropas ya que las tropas rusas no
pueden desembarcar aquí por que
romperían todos sus barcos aquí mismo
los habitantes de esa atentos ante
bombardeos desde otras zonas se
enfrentan a dos opciones huir o quedarse
y luchar en su más reciente declaración
el presidente volodymyr selenski se
mostró a favor de negociar con rusia y
propuso al primer ministro de israel
naftalí bennett para mediar en las
conversaciones de igual forma pidió a la
otan que dé una respuesta clara sobre
una posible adhesión de ucrania a la
alianza en medio de sus declaraciones
quedó en evidencia el choque de
información entre las partes para
detallar las cifras de militares
fallecidos tanto del lado ucraniano como
del lado ruso estas son las cifras que
informo selenski
en disco alrededor de 1.300 militares
han muerto hasta hoy en nuestro país y
del lado ruso más de 12 miles es una
proporción de 1 a 10 no estoy feliz de
que 12.000 de ellos hayan muerto esta no
es mi visión del mundo tienen padres la
mayoría de ellos no saben a dónde fueron
enviados no saben nada
del lado ruso solo se informó hace 10
días de 500 soldados rusos fallecidos y
hoy el jefe del centro de control de
defensa ruso acusó a grupos
nacionalistas ucranianos de atentar
contra civiles de esa misma nación y
aseguró que ellos son los responsables
de la catástrofe humanitaria que vive
ucrania
como resultado de estas acciones
criminales y traicioneras de las
autoridades ucranianas principalmente en
relación con su propio pueblo la
población civil se ve obligada a
sobrevivir en condiciones inhumanas sin
calefacción electricidad suministro de
agua alimentos y medicinas
la situación humanitaria más difícil se
ha desarrollado en varios cientos de
miles de personas incluidos extraño
están retenidas por la fuerza por
nacionalistas que amenazan con violencia
física que tiene cualquier intento de
abandonar la ciudad we will have the
sword naciones unidas dice haber
recibido informes creíbles de que las
fuerzas rusas se están utilizando
municiones de racimo en zonas muy
pobladas de ucrania se trata de armas
que constan de un contenedor que se abre
en el aire y dispersa grandes cantidades
de submuniciones explosivas sobre un
área amplia en hardcore los escuadrones
antibombas se están tratando de eliminar
estos explosivos
desde que las municiones rusas empezaron
a golpear edificios residenciales como
este en heart con el escuadrón
antibombas de la ciudad ha estado
desplazándose de una zona a otra
despejando y desarmando una por una las
pequeñas bombas que los proyectiles
esparcen por zonas densamente pobladas
recibimos una llamada de que se había
encontrado un objeto sospechoso en la
calle de tractor o whitney que alrededor
del 40 por ciento de estas submuniciones
no explotan al caer al suelo pero
podrían hacerlo en cualquier momento así
que el peligro está en todos lados está
cayó en un parque infantil la metralla y
los proyectiles son retirados y luego
van a parar a las afueras de la ciudad
desde el comienzo de la guerra hemos
estado extrayendo partes de los
explosivos de las calles de hardcore
aquí en particular se pueden encontrar
partes de misiles uragán y es mersch
esto es lo que utilizan sobre nuestras
tropas pero hubo casos en que estas
bombas de racimo alcanzaron casas calles
de la ciudad y a la población civil
como muestran estas imágenes las bombas
de racimo están hechas para extenderse
por grandes áreas están formadas por una
cáscara hueca que se rompe en pleno
vuelo dejando escapar docenas o incluso
cientos de bombas más pequeñas llamadas
bombetas en todo craneal las cáscaras
exteriores de estas bombas de racimo
marcan el paisaje una señal de la
destrucción a la que condujeron la
oficina del alto comisionado de la onu
para los derechos humanos ha recibido
informes creíbles de que las fuerzas
rusas han utilizado municiones de racimo
incluso en zonas pobladas los ataques
indiscriminados están prohibidos por el
derecho internacional humanitario cerca
de 100 países en el mundo acordaron en
2008 un tratado que prohíbe las
municiones de racimo debido al daño
indiscriminado que infligen pero ucrania
eeuu y rusia se han negado a firmarlo
el jefe de la agencia espacial rusa
roscósmos advirtió que la estación
espacial internacional podría caer a la
tierra argumentando que dejaría de
enviar las naves espaciales que la
mantienen en órbita debido a las
sanciones contra rusia sin embargo otras
empresas están interviniendo para
ofrecer planes de contingencia ya
principios de mes la nasa había
anunciado que buscará garantizar las
operaciones sin depender de rusia
este vídeo publicado por la agencia
espacial rusa roscósmos muestra el
segmento ruso de la estación espacial
internacional desprendiéndose dejándolo
a merced de la atracción gravitatoria de
la tierra el jefe de roscósmos dice que
occidente se arriesga a que esto ocurra
y afirma que la órbita de la estación no
lo llevaría a caer sobre rusia sino en
otro lugar sobre quién podría caer la
estación espacial internacional de 500
toneladas la población de otros países
incluidos los dirigidos por perros de la
guerra deberían pensar en el precio de
las sanciones que iniciaron contra los
cosmos se trata de una amenaza vacía o
una preocupación seria rusia es
responsable de mantener la estación a
flote y es cierto que si cayera a la
tierra no toda el ya se quemaría en la
atmósfera pero rusia también es
responsable de apartar la estación
espacial internacional de los desechos
espaciales si deja de cooperar podría
estar poniendo en peligro la vida de
tres de sus cosmonautas que están a
bordo
en cualquier caso empresas como northrop
grumman y space six están interviniendo
para asegurarse de que la estación en
órbita y sea maniobrable pero para la
nasa el riesgo no es solo una caída
repentina a la tierra sino una triste
pérdida de colaboración científica
internacional
sería muy difícil para nosotros operar
por nuestra cuenta la estación es una
asociación internacional que se creó con
dependencias conjuntas que es lo que
hace que sea un programa tan increíble
el desmantelamiento controlado de la
estación espacial internacional está
previsto para 2031 cuando se dirigirá
hacia una tumba acuática en el océano
pacifico el conflicto craneano también
dejó sentir su impacto en viena la
capital austriaca donde se desarrollan
los diálogos nucleares con irán a punto
de triunfar hace una semana las
negociaciones se ven ahora amenazadas
por la exigencia de garantías
adicionales por parte de moscú
tras 11 meses de trabajo las principales
potencias del mundo ultimaban detalles
para salvar el acuerdo nuclear con irán
de 2015 pero el proceso se detuvo
bruscamente mientras abandonan el
palacio de viena donde se celebran las
conversaciones los negociadores no
ocultan su frustración por fin and
testing which ya casi hemos llegado el
texto está casi listo no estamos lejos
de las notas a pie de página así que ya
lo pueden imaginar
un estancamiento atribuido a moscú que
en el último momento hizo demandas
inesperadas golpeada por las sanciones
occidentales tras su invasión a ucrania
rusia exige garantías de que estas
medidas de represalia no afecten su
cooperación económica con irán
las nuevas sanciones relacionadas con
rusia no tienen ninguna relación con el
acuerdo nuclear con irán
no deberían tener ningún impacto en su
eventual aplicación wind no pretendemos
ofrecer a rusia nada nuevo o específico
en el contexto de estas sanciones
los países europeos exigen que se llegue
a un acuerdo con urgencia pero por el
momento no se ha fijado una fecha para
la reanudación de las negociaciones
cuanto más larga sea la pausa mayor será
el riesgo de que las conversaciones se
entren en una especie de estado zombie
en el que no se produzcan avances ni
fracasos pero irán continúa con sus
avances nucleares la firma de un nuevo
acuerdo nuclear marcaría el fin de las
sanciones estadounidenses contra teherán
millones de barriles de petróleo y
grandes cantidades de gas iraní podrían
llegar al mercado internacional lo que
podría disminuir el precio de los
hidrocarburos y reducir la dependencia
de la energía rusa
miles de franceses marcharon en parís la
capital gala para pedir acciones
climáticas concretas previo a las
elecciones presidenciales de abril los
manifestantes inundaron las calles
cuando europa está empezando a
experimentar un fuerte aumento en los
costos de la energía debido a la guerra
en ucrania y a las sanciones a rusia que
es el mayor proveedor de energía para la
unión europea
moscú provee más del 40 por ciento del
gas natural más de una cuarta parte de
las importaciones de petróleo y casi la
mitad de las de carbón
en otras noticias en chile comenzó
oficialmente el gobierno de gabriel
boric como nuevo presidente en su primer
día al frente del ejecutivo moriche se
reunió con miembros de los pueblos
originarios de los que los mapuches son
los más numerosos y quienes mantienen
una lucha mayor con el estado chileno
por el reconocimiento de sus territorios
patricia luna corresponsal en santiago
tiene los detalles
con retraso sobre el horario inicial
previsto partió la primera jornada del
nuevo presidente de chile gabriel boric
en la moneda al saludo militar
protocolar siguió una ceremonia de
encuentro con los pueblos originarios
recordemos que en chile existen 10
pueblos originarios aunque el
mayoritario más conocido en el que se
auto reconoce un 10 por ciento de la
población es el pueblo mapuche en esta
ceremonia participaron sabios sabios
representantes ancestrales y miembros de
esta comunidad de lo que fue una serie
de prerrogativas y también intercambios
para desear un nuevo buen comienzo a
este nuevo ciclo que parte en el país y
que estará marcado por un trabajo
intercultural se dijo un 6 desde la
moneda en el que se incidió en que chile
va a ser ahora reconocido como un
territorio plurinacional en esta
ceremonia participó tanto el presidente
de había el boliche como la primera dama
irina cara manos que después se
trasladaron a la catedral de santiago
para participar de una ceremonia
ecuménica en la que también se realizó
una oración por el nuevo gobierno y por
el pueblo de chile mañana el presidente
de boliche y la primera dama karamanos
se desplazan a uno de los barrios más
desfavorecidos de santiago la pintana
donde tendrán una actividad de
intercambio con la comunidad estas son
las actividades que marcan por tanto el
primer fin de semana del nuevo gobierno
de chile en nicaragua la opositora del
gobierno del presidente daniel ortega
cristiana chamorro fue declarada
culpable de varios delitos entre ellos
lavado de dinero y falsedad ideológica
la aspirante a la presidencia en las
pasadas elecciones fue arrestada en
junio de 2021 era la figura de la
oposición con mayor peso en el país la
fiscalía pide 13 años de cárcel para la
opositora
el juicio contra chamorro hace parte de
una serie de procesos judiciales contra
líderes y críticos al gobierno
encarcelados antes de los comicios
hablamos con main erc artist abogado de
la familia chamorro y esto fue lo que
nos dijo
bueno realmente viene a hacer algo
similar con los otros que están
detenidos por ejemplo en cuanto a la
pena para ella están pidiendo una pena
de ocho años y otros opositores que
están detenidos también en la mayoría de
las mujeres como la señora violeta
granera o tamara dávila fueron
sentenciados a ocho años para personas
como juan sebastián que también era un
precandidato a la presidencia
también él fue sentenciado a 13 años
entonces casi las personas que estaban
involucradas en actividades de política
y que fueron detenidos están
sentenciados en un rango dentro de 9 a
13 años de prisión es lo que sucede es
lo siguiente nosotros desde el punto de
vista legal lo vemos en cualquier fallo
del juez que luzca parcial o imparcial
pero para nosotros violan las leyes
nicaragüenses
violan el debido proceso violan la
tutela judicial efectiva nosotros lo
tenemos que recurrir en el recurso de
apelación así llegamos al final de este
informativo gracias su sintonía
continúan con nosotros que volvemos en
breve con más noticias
[Música]